what advice do you have for those who
have weak poor or otherwise ineffective
leaders how do you manipulate that
situation mm-hmm so again III think I
may have actually answered this question
before mm-hmm but I'll answer to get
sure when I when you are in a situation
like this when you got somebody that's
weak or ineffective leader or a poor
leader the answer is always the same
which news you lead you lead yourself
and I hope people that listen to podcast
all the regular you all knew what I was
going to say there you all know that
when someone is not leading you then you
lead them you pick up the slack for the
weakness it my leaders want to come up
with a plan cool I will my leader
doesn't want to give a brief that's fine
I will my leader doesn't want to mentor
the younger troops that's okay I will do
it leader doesn't want to take the blame
when something goes wrong that's fine
with me
I'm gonna take the blame and you think
about that one that one can be tricky
because you think well I'm gonna look
bad in front of the in front of the more
senior boss now think about it from the
senior boss's position if if you work
for me echo and the boss comes in and we
the mission was a failure
and I'm the I'm the guy that's in charge
and I say sorry boss we failed
it was echos fault and echo goes hey sir
it was my fault here's what happened
here's the mistakes I made and here's
what I do to fix it next time who do you
respect more yeah of course I'm looking
to promote you you know I actually want
to promote you I don't fire myself for
being a guy that's passing the buck and
passing responsibility or not taking
ownership of anything so imagine what
that looks like before you get all
intimidated by taking the blame for
something and think you're gonna look
bad and think you're gonna get fired
think about what it looks like from the
senior perspective and you actually have
to imagine what it will look like
underneath you you have to see it from
your perspective cuz it's even when you
think about their perspective you still
can be in fear of it you think oh I'm
the guy that's
blame I'm the one that's gonna get fired
no and and am I saying this like blanket
that there's some times where if the
boss screw something up really bad like
let's say it was something like
classified information got left out and
it was your boss that literally left it
out and you go no it was me well first
of all you're not telling the truth
right so you're not telling the truth
and the person made a mistake that's and
that there's no excuse for yeah so
that's not a situation that I'm talking
about and if your boss was the type of
person that said yes I'm gonna put the
blame on him I would burn them alive
like actually here's what really
happened so I'm not talking about that
type of situation but when you're doing
an operational thing where there's
mistakes that get made and your boss is
scared to take ownership of them take
ownership of them mm not that it you
will win in the long run now you know
here's the part that is crucial and
critical and the most challenging part
of this and that is when you step up and
lead you want to make sure you aren't
stepping up and stepping on your leader
you don't want to step into their little
spotlight you don't want to impose
yourself in their leadership limelight
and glory you don't want to do that you
you you can't do that you want them to
get the credit you don't want to have
them be intimidated by you in any way
and this is hard because when you start
taking ownership for stuff it's very it
can be very intimidating for the person
that's above you because they think dang
this guy just he's just a bold bastard
then stepping up and taking charge of
stuff and they might get intimidated
that so so what you have to do is you
have to do some some indirect maneuver
warfare here and for instance if they
don't wanna what they don't want to come
up with a plan maybe you start saying
hey sir what do you think of this would
this be a good plan mhm and maybe if
you're if they're not mentoring the
younger guys maybe say hey you know what
I want to do this up I want to spend
some time with the guys after work do
you mind if I have a
session with them kind of go over what
we learned on last appointment or hey
about this new regulatory thing that's
come out in the business world and I
want to get our younger troops to know
it do you mind if I teach a class on
that so you're asking them permission
and you might even say you know hey I
think it would look really good for you
too if we were doing this do you want to
make them look good and those are the
ways that you do that you step up and
lead but make sure you're not stepping
on your leader because that could
backfire and you could end up in a
situation where they feel intimidated
and you're getting put in the doghouse
or fired or demoted or in trouble
because they feel intimidated by you so
use caution if you have a good leader
some leaders just aren't that aggressive
mm-hmm and when you start getting
aggressive they start they actually like
the fact that you're getting aggressive
and they like I mean I work for some
people that love the fact that I would
step up to take charge they had no
problem with it because they were good
confident leaders it's the insecure
leader you have to watch out for the
insecure leader that's worried about
looking bad and that's another two
change perspective again on this when
you as a leader have somebody that's
stepping up and taking charge ask and
you start feeling intimidated by it ask
yourself why it's probably your ego
you're being a weak leader by being
intimidated by your subordinates if your
subordinate is doing your job and doing
it better than you let get step up and
start looking how can you go up the
chain of command how can you look up and
out how what other areas can you focus
on since that leader has stepped up and
is making things happen that's awesome
that is awesome
we want that mm-hmm that's decentralized
command that's building other leaders
underneath you which is what your goal
as a leader should always be
and I'll tell you every time I see
someone that goes oh I got a weak leader
I'm always like lucky you yeah yeah
lucky you take advantage of that take
advantage of it do whatever you want you
have such a good opportunity when you
have a weak leader above you don't look
at that don't don't get all downtrodden
because it just doesn't motivate you
awesome
motivate yourself get chart getting
charge of things take advantage of it
make things happen it's awesome to have
a weak leader I love it get after it
it's good to give me so much mobility in
my in my in my job right I'm so much
more mobility and if I've got someone
hey if I got someone that's a strong
leader that's great too but weak leaders
no factor hmm I'm gonna take advantage
of it yes feel like you yes you got a
weak leader and and you're kind of um
you're not stepping up you're
essentially allowing the the group the
team the objectives to kind of fail in a
way you're kind of allowing it and then
in a way to depends on what you do but
in a way you're kind of be being like
hey all right you're allowing the excuse
to be valid you know we're which kind of
makes it invalid really when you're like
hey I could step up but hey it's the
leader so as long as it's not my fault
you know that my leaders not that good
you know it's you're really not taking
much ownership yeah just point your
finger at your leader and say this is a
weak leader yeah that's not what we do
here not what we do at all and the times
where I've had weak leaders I I always
took advantage of it like I said one
time and I've talked about this on the
podcast before we fired our leader you
know we had a little mutiny that only
happened once for me but you know it
happens that I mean I I don't know the
all the details of that but in a way
isn't that you just staffing up and
making it happen I mean that's really
the impending result like dang that's
that's kind of where we're gonna arrive
that really giving us stepping up if if
that's how it goes down that's how it
goes down but you stepped up you solve
the problem if there's a problem and
that was a problem there's your solution
anything
yes up and down the chain of command you
gotta own it for sure